James LaPorta reporting for Newsweek who
by the way James LaPorta has watched a
lot of the David Pakman show he is
reporting along with Tom O'Connor that
the US military has 14,000 troops ready
to go to the us-mexico border and is
sending 5200 troops now they will be
there by the end of the week in order to
fight the immigrant caravan that is
months away and dwindling in size every
single day why probably because the
midterms are next week I'm sorry I
should at least tell you what they claim
they claim that the immigrant caravan
represents an invasion of our country
that must be stopped
that's according to Donald Trump this is
playing politics with the military
because there is no invasion we're gonna
hear actually later in the show from a
Fox News host who admits that there is
no invasion it's just not happening
Trump is claiming that dangerous Middle
Easterners are mixed in with Hispanics
and they're about to invade the reality
is that the caravan has already shrunk
from 7,000 to 3,500 people it is weeks
if not months from reaching the United
States border with Mexico and Donald
Trump is using active-duty military to
stand around as props as political props
to help Republicans and to take
attention away from the right-wing
violence that is plaguing this country
understand the games that are being
played here white supremacists grocery
store shooting mag Abama sends a dozen
pipe bombs anti-semitic synagogue
shooting that leads 11 dead including
people as old as 97 years of age and
we're spending billions to send troops
to the border because of people that are
a thousand miles away who are looking
for a better place for their families
and are looking to seek asylum in the
legally prescribed way military members
will potentially be missing the
Thanksgiving holiday with their families
because Donald Trump has decided that
they need to stand at the border waiting
for the caravan of asylum seekers to
arrive there will be many more soldiers
than migrants they even have come up
with a propaganda name for the operation
which is I can barely say it without
throwing up a little bit in my mouth
operation faithful Patriot
is 5200 and potentially as many as
14,000 troops standing at the border
waiting for asylum seekers that are a
thousand miles away I've said it before
I'll say it again if we took the money
that these troops cost us to put them at
the border and we spent it instead on
improving the situation in the countries
that the migrants are coming from we
would all be better off and there will
be right-wingers who say David the US
has no responsibility to help other
countries have a better situation that's
right we don't but if we were rational
and we realize the amount of money that
we're spending billions for troops at
the border we could spend the same
improving other countries we would
reduce the demand for people to come to
the United States we would build
goodwill which by the way we could use
at this point and we would stimulate
economies that might end up doing
business with the United States and
increase tourism and have positive
externalities this is a propaganda war
and it's in full swing and you are
paying for it I am thrilled to tell you
that one of today's sponsors is simple
habit calm slash Pakman where you can go
and get a seven day totally free trial
of an app that I use personally and love
I've talked to you before about the
benefits of meditation just simply
sitting there observing what it is that
your mind wants to do has been a great
thing for me we have so much evidence
growing all the time that this is just a
good thing for people to do and one of
the best tools you'll be able to find
anywhere online for guiding you through
meditation is simple habit it just won
the 2018 Google Play award for best
well-being app a very well deserved
award they have guided meditations by
some of the most respected mindfulness
experts from the east and west you can
choose from a huge selection of
five-minute meditations each designed
specifically for where you are or what
you're doing or the mood that you're in
they have meditations for falling asleep
for when you're waking up for your daily
commute when you've just gotten home
from work
there are meditations specially crafted
to help people deal with anxiety or to
get focused before doing something
difficult and simple habit lets you keep
track of your progress by giving you
feedback about how much you're
meditating how many days in a row you've
been meditating it's a really
comprehensive and well put together app
go check it out you can try it free for
seven days at simple habit calm /
Packman i've put a link underneath this
video